on doing testing in the villages very
early on
they've also we've also worked together
on doing some testing in underserved
areas which has been been very very
important I'm gonna go through some of
the the numbers kind of where we are
some of the things that we're doing to
continue in the in the fight against
Cove in nineteen the coronavirus from
very beginning we've stressed a few main
points one is protecting the vulnerable
those who are elderly and then those who
have significant comorbidities and we're
going to talk about some of the things
we're doing to continue that effort but
that's very very important the mortality
is very very clear skewing heavily in
that direction so those are folks that
that need support I will talk about the
expansion of testing which is very
robust now the social distancing which
is still very important support for
hospital healthcare workers and then
obviously you know introduction of the
virus into Florida so if you look at
where we are and kind of where we've
been particularly you know over the last
month when we started this clearly the
testing levels were low at the time CDC
said only test somebody who's 65 and
older has symptoms it was in China maybe
some other international places part of
that was just there was a limited
testing capacity so you look kind of the
March beginning of April we were testing
at probably similar levels per capita
that other states were except for the
Northeast but but much different than
what we are now but the positivity rate
was basically about 10% for those first
four to six weeks and so you know if you
did 10,000 tests you get a thousand
positive is kind of what we were looking
at there then as we got into April
we started seeing positive movement in
the positivity rate the beginning of May
through that second week of June was
really the best testing that we had had
going on in the state of Florida in
terms of low positivity we were
expanding the number of tests being
conducted but the amount of people the
percentage of people testing positive
was very very low so you look at the
beginning of May you know we were under
5% all the way through June 13th were
4.9%
now the June June 13th week 6 to 6 7 to
the 13th you started to see even though
4.9 is still still good you know we were
3.3 percent the week before started to
see a little increase in the positivity
part of that was driven by discrete
outbreaks that we were seeing in
different parts of the state but I think
that was kind of the beginning of then
the next week we get into and again were
you know testing a lot of people 230,000
but we went to nine point five percent
positivity and so you're testing a lot
of people but the percentage testing
positive is higher and then the
following week a huge increase in the
number of tests that are done but also
an increase in the positivity from nine
point five to eleven point nine percent
and then this past week we did almost
400,000 tests but had just under 15%
positivity and really when you look at
the positivity it's been about 14 15 %
pretty consistently now for more than a
week I mean really probably about eight
to ten days so you know when you're
looking at cases and I'll talk about
this a little bit more in a minute for
every case that's documented there are
many more infections that have actually
occurred we only diagnose a small
fraction of the total number of
infections so if you are at 5%
positivity and you test 50,000 and then
you test a hundred thousand the
positivity stays the same yeah you'll
have twice as many tests come back
positive but it's not really evidence
that it's more prevalent when you are
seeing the positivity increase more
people out of whatever amount you're
doing testing positive you know that's
an indication of the positivity
increasing and so some of these things
we've seen over the last eight days and
other media say oh this record case it's
basically been the same I mean yeah when
we do 85,000 tests we're gonna have more
for doing 40,000 tests
we're gonna have less positives but the
percentage has been pretty consistent
now this is
we want to get back down on that three
three four percent that we were in May
and early June at the same time you know
the 15 percent that's a far cry from
what you were seeing in places like the
Northeast they were 30 40 50 percent
early in the pandemic and in fact you
know we are now at the point where we've
tested 10 percent of the state's
population so 2.2 million people
we got about obviously a little under 22
million Floridians and so that's a
that's a lot of tests but I think it's
something that was significant we wanted
to expand testing and and we've done it
and then here's the stats for the last
week 30 almost 400,000 people tested
14.8% tested positive so again if you
take the may percentage we would have
probably been four or five percent so
that's going to generate a lot more test
positive test when you're testing at
fourteen point eight percent and the
positivity is not uniform throughout the
state of Florida if you go down to
miami-dade you know they've been twenty
percent you look at Hillsborough they've
been between fifteen and twenty percent
I think Orange County has been over
fifteen percent and then there's other
places that have been less and you know
may not be some places where one or two
percent in May you know it's now they
maybe six or seven so you have seen an
increase in the positivity but there are
a lot of parts of Florida that are still
in the single digits so obviously we
want to keep it that way and then be
able to do and then the median age is
really significant and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a minute
the median age of everybody testing
right now positive for this past week is
thirty six and as we've seen the cases
increase the median age every single day
has been in the 30s sometimes as low as
33 now why is that important well
because this is a virus that does not
affect all age groups equally it's much
more lethal for people who were in their
80s and 90s than it is in your 20s and
30s and I'll go through some of the
numbers but basically you know if you're
under 40 and you don't have significant
comorbidities you know the fatality rate
for this is it's pretty close to zero
so who is testing positive
it's just as important as how many
people are testing positive this is a
probably a two decade shift from where
we were with the median age at the end
of March beginning of April we had been
in the 60s then in the 50s and then as
this upswing has really been driven by a
lot of people in their 20s and 30s
testing positive and so here's a example
of kind of the risk profile by age group
which is very very important so you look
and kind of those the younger kind of
the 15 to 44 that is where the bulk of
these positive tests are now coming from
and particularly that 25 to 34 year old
age group I mean far in a way it's
blowing everybody out in terms of
positive tests you know you look at the
kovat related fatalities and in those
age groups I mean the rate is incredibly
incredibly low many of the people in
their 20s and 30s who are testing
positive are asymptomatic they're being
tested because maybe they were exposed
maybe for workplace and then those who
develop symptoms and mostly develop mild
symptoms and so these are the folks who
are just simply less at risk than the
folks who you know are 65 and plus and
there's a big difference to in the risk
profile between 85 and plus 75 to 85 is
definitely lower and then 65 to 75 is
definitely lower than that and then
obviously as you go down further absent
comorbidities it goes down very very low
so the the case growth is really being
driven primarily in these low risk
groups now at the same time you know
just because you're 21 and you may not
have significant symptoms it does not
mean that you can't infect other people
and and I think that that's something
that we're obviously concerned about but
this is really the picture of where we
were since the cases started going up in
the last month you know has really been
driven by those age groups right there
and in fact if you look that's the cases
by age in the state of Florida the age
that has the most cases in the state of
Florida is to age 21 and again without
Co more
abilities present you're looking at
practically a zero percent fatality rate
obviously as it gets older it goes down
you know that's obviously a good thing
you know we don't want to see cases in
in the upper age groups but really it
shows you kind of that real significant
increase in those 20s and thirty year
olds testing positive that's where most
of the community transmission is really
coming from particularly in metro areas
like you know like the Orlando and
Hillsborough if you look at their median
age that's dropped dramatically in some
of those metro areas that's fueled by by
some of those folks and those age groups
that we're seeing so it's so when you
see the cases obviously it's it's it's
something that that we're seeing but it
also does matter who's testing positive
in terms of mortality and morbidity and
if you look and people don't usually
talk about this the case fatality rate
by state Florida is much lower than many
of the other major states so case
fatality is just the number of
fatalities related to Cova divided by
the number of Kovac cases and so we're
now I think you know under two percent
and that's been trending downward and I
think that that's a reflection of the
fact that a lot of the newer cases over
the last month have been driven by
people who are at very low risk for
fatality so part of it too and I think
the doctors will talk about some of the
things you know they also have more
tools at their disposal to be able to
treat people as they come in and again
that you know the whole idea of
flattening the curve was not that you
would not have more infections I mean no
one said that you can just somehow stop
it the idea was you kind of spread it
out so that the healthcare system is in
a position to be able to handle what
happens and clearly you know we did that
in Florida March and April no problem
had very relatively low hospital
occupancy we had a lot of availability
and then even as they put the elective
surgeries back in most parts of Florida
you still have about a twenty five
percent availability and so that's part
of it but it's also the treatments and
the
things learning from other countries
other states and so they've done a
really good job about that but you know
we have probably the most vulnerable
population but then to have a case
fatality rate that's now below two and
of course many more infections and cases
so the actual infection fatality rate is
gonna be much much lower than that
here's what we're looking for total
tests in Florida three-day rolling
average you know that little peak in May
I've said this before but that's
artificial that was about six weeks
worth of backlog negatives that got
dumped over a two day period so really
it has been a pretty smooth ascent from
where we were in March until where we
are now at the beginning of July and
we're averaging I think over the past
week I think it's like 60 to 65 thousand
test results a day coming in part of
that is because I'll talk about what
Florida has done to expand testing part
of it the hospitals you know they're
testing everyone coming in for
procedures if they're in for for
childbirth if they get in a car accident
they're getting swab so you have way
more testing being done at the hospitals
than you did in March and April one of
the things we look at are these syndrome
attic indicators and again you know
sometimes their signal in this sometimes
there's noise and this clearly you know
you can see if you would go back in May
this was something that was incredibly
stable and low throughout most of them
late April all of May beginning of June
and then as you see you start to see in
the second week of June a little bit of
an increase in the Cova die like illness
so this is people that go to the ed4
kovat or influenza like illness --is
that we track so those though these are
edy visits so then you look as we get
into the middle of June you see the
increase in the kovat like illness
visits and then it goes up even more
towards the end of June and then really
at the very end of June you know you see
and then you have seen it kind of taper
back too soon to know whether that's a
that's a sustained trend but obviously
those are sin dramatic indicators you
know that we're looking at when you get
positive test results sometimes these
labs will take a week to turn the tester
and so you could be getting a positive
test today and someone may have taken
that that test seven days ago they may
have been infected seven days before
that so chances are they've probably
already if they need to probably already
visited by the time some of these test
results come back in and so it's
unfortunately you know you're not in a
situation where these are instant
instantaneous test results but those are
things to look at these kovat and
influenza like illness indicators so
we're gonna continue to monitor that and
I said before I'm just gonna stress that
cases are simply detected infections
there are and have been way more
infections than documented cases and so
if you see five thousand cases ten
thousand just understand that is not the
sum total of the people that have been
infected if we were doing eighty
thousand tests a day in March or April
those numbers would have been
dramatically higher in terms of case
numbers than what we ended up having and
here's here's an example of what we mean
by that and this is recently the end of
June CDC put out they did antibody
testing and seroprevalence surveys in
different parts of the country they did
one here in southern Florida in the four
counties Martin Palm Beach Broward and
miami-dade and if you look they were
testing for the presence of antibodies
IgM IgG and this was done over a period
April 6 to April 10th at that time there
had been 10,500 cases reported based on
the antibodies and the seroprevalence
CDC believes that there were actually 11
times more infections at the time in
southern Florida so that's 117 thousand
four hundred infections that had
actually occurred and if you think about
the antibodies the IgG takes about two
weeks to develop IgM probably about
seven days so if you're testing kind of
at the beginning of April you know these
are infections that may have happened in
February but certainly the first couple
weeks of March probably not that much
later by and large and so that
seroprevalence clearly would have
increased by the time you get into April
and then so if you want to know
what the seroprevalence was on you know
April 10th you know you really need to
figure out when those infections
occurred when the antibodies developed
and so I would imagine and the
University of Miami has done this for
miami-dade they've had infection rate I
think 16 per times higher than the
number of cases we do antibody testing
throughout the state at our drive-thru
sites for health care workers and for
first responders and what we're finding
places like Miami 7 to 10 percent test
positive for antibodies some of the
places like Orlando Jacksonville you
know they're more in like the three
three and a half percent but still that
is showing you that the prevalence is is
not captured by just the detected cases
now that means a couple of things it
means that the virus is more widespread
than what the cases would say it also
means that the fatalities are less than
a simple raw case fatality rate because
you'd have to include all the infections
doing a seroprevalence and so that's why
CDC now estimates the infection fatality
rate for Corona to be about 0.26 I think
their best estimate you know in Florida
if we do have a one point nine percent
case fatality rate if you are gonna say
something like ten eleven percent higher
you know that would obviously bump that
down to to about point one nine so but I
bring this up just because I think it's
important that people understand you
know how this has developed and these
were infections that likely occurred
before there was any 15-day to stop the
spread before we you know had thought
that there was necessarily widespread so
I think it shows this thing has been
circulating for longer in our country
than we initially thought kind of at the
beginning of March I mean - beginning of
March we're testing people it's like oh
my gosh we have a case like this is it
that's the infection and in in reality
that was a function of the testing
criteria had you had a broader testing
criteria you would have picked up more
more cases at that time and I and I
bring that up to just because you know
as you see cases just people just should
put it into context about what's going
on you know there's no need to really be
be fearful about it I mean we can talk
about the different steps that
individuals
can take you know that we're going to
take statewide but at the end of the day
you know this is something that's been
around for quite some time I think this
is important and I know some of the
physicians here will talk about it but
one of the things that I think did not
get as much attention at the time and
only now I think people are starting to
realize is when the corona virus
pandemic national emergency was declared
in the middle of March
CDC looked at the Edie visits across the
country for things like heart stroke and
other serious illnesses and what you saw
was a major major decline in the number
of people visiting the IDI for things
like like heart problems now no one
believes that those problems all of a
sudden just stopped what happened was
people were probably fearful about going
into the hospital because they thought
you know maybe they would catch the
virus there maybe they thought that the
hospitals didn't have capacity to deal
with them who knows maybe they thought
that they were told to stay at home
maybe they thought that means don't even
give medical but they're probably a lot
of reasons for it but this definitely
happened
and CDC's recent report basically
attributes or says it may attribute the
observed excess mortality not associated
with kovat over the last several months
to people putting off visiting hospitals
for really life-threatening situations
what happens is you may not die right
then but the problems worsen and then by
the time you do present in the hospital
your end up you're sicker than what you
otherwise would be and your mortality
risk as has increased dramatically so
people should just be be very they
should understand that the hospitals are
safe place to be this is something that
you do not want to put off there's
capacity they have great safety
protocols you're less likely to get
coronavirus here then a lot of private
residences or a lot of other things you
could be doing so so please come in and
don't let those problems Fester
that does impact apps
luli will impact mortality if if you
don't come and get the care that you
need when you need it so our number one
priority throughout this whole thing is
to protect the vulnerable because of the
disproportionate impact the virus has on
people who are 65 and up and people that
have significant comorbidities we've
advised really since March and even as
we got into the different phases the
guidance has never changed about people
who are 65 and up we're recommending and
advising to avoid crowds and to minimize
close contact with people who are not
not in your household that is the the
safest way to make sure that you're not
putting yourself in a situation where
you could contract the virus and I think
by and large in the vivianne here in the
villages is important because you know
they've really I think he did this from
the very beginning I remember talking to
Gary Lester in early March I was like
you know you they had a plan they've
done a lot of stuff and you know it's
really made an impact and I know one of
the one of the physicians was going to
talk about you know some of the other
areas in this system where the
populations younger you actually see
more cases and even more Edie and in
hospital missions then you see here at
the villages and a lot of that is
because of people really taking making
the effort to protect themselves so the
message for our elderly population is to
avoid crowds and minimize contact
outside the home this virus is
circulating in a circulating more widely
with people who were in their 20s and
30s so anyone in multi-generational
housing you know that's something that
should definitely be a concern and then
obviously if you're somebody you know
that has either kids or grandkids in
that age group you know that's something
that you should be cognizant of as well
also underlying condition so if you look
the younger you are you know the
fatality rate is incredibly low close to
zero but there regardless of age if you
do have some of these significant
comorbidities you are definitely at an
increased risk from the corona virus and
some of the things I think people would
understand and just instinctively you
know anything with having to do
the lungs like a cystic fibrosis
obviously if you have a serious heart
condition but what they see a lot in the
hospital with the patients who may not
be in their 70s or 80s may be in their
50s that is the difference between maybe
having an asymptomatic illness or
minimal symptoms or an illness that
requires hospitalization are some
comorbidities like diabetes and obesity
that's of those are very very common
comorbidities that hospitals really
throughout Florida I think are seeing
over and over again and so you know the
guidance for folks in those situations
is the same as for 65 and up you'll be
sure to avoid crowds and and minimize
close contact outside the home if you're
somebody who's in those categories
because your risk is elevated due to
those Co comorbidities of course our
long-term care facilities is kind of
where the most at-risk population is we
did early on I know I know some of the
doctors I think dr. Lizardo will talk
about the impact but you know we
protected these long-term care
facilities you know we banned having
patients be readmitted if they were
covent positive because we feared that
that would help really spread the
outbreak against the most vulnerable and
I think that that was that was the right
policy but we also understood is okay if
you have somebody who's kovat positive
who's a resident of a long-term care
facility and they're in the hospital but
they're medically stable we don't want
them back in the nursing room they can't
be isolated because obviously you're
putting the other residents at risk but
if they don't need to be authorized it
would be good if they could be isolated
appropriately so what we started to do
in April was established koba dedicated
nursing facilities so we now have 12
Cova dedicated nursing facilities
throughout the state of Florida that are
able to have patients who are kovat
positive but that do not their health
does not require hospitalization and
unfortunately you know even though the
mortality rate is much higher for people
who were over 75 you know we are finding
a lot of nursing home residents and
long-term care residents who do test
positive and who have symptoms that
are short of what would require
hospitalization so you now have these
facilities all across the state of
Florida and that's about 750 beds that
can be used for folks who are
convalescing and who are isolating and
that's really this is really worth it
because if you put someone back into a
long-term care facility that is still
contagious and they cannot be isolated
that is going to end up spreading in
those facilities and you're going to end
up seeing more patients come to the
hospital so I want to thank secretary
Mayhew for working hard over the last
couple months to do this I think this is
going to be really significant you know
we didn't have this in March and April
we first one was brought in the middle
of April now that we have this really
puts everyone I think in a better
situation is better for long-term care
facilities better for hospitals and and
really better for better for the
residents and all these situations the
other thing we're doing from April
through probably the middle of June we
went through and tested the long-term
care residents tested staff which was
important but what we're also doing
going forward is all staff members at
long-term care facilities need to be
tested once every two weeks and so we
have a program in place we're providing
the different types of tests for that
now I will remind people you know you
are going to see positive tests with the
staff when we get it the first time we
had about a three percent positivity
rate now that this is something that is
more prevalent in the community that is
likely to be reflective reflected in
these staff members and so I'm hoping
that it's lower than the 15% and it may
be because they have tested lower than
the general population throughout the
whole time but we're apt to see that now
what we will do is obviously they will
be isolated and they won't be
interacting with the residents and so
it's important screening mechanism to
keep doing but you know you got almost
200,000 people who work in these from
over 4,000 facilities throughout the
state of Florida
so you've over 200,000 almost 200,000
folks who are going to be tested every
two weeks is that's gonna be a lot of
tests and it's going to be and it will
be some new cases we
that question but if you isolate them
then we're protecting I think the
vulnerable in the way that we really
need to and of course you know we have
almost 85% of the corona related
fatalities have occurred in age group 65
and plus I think nationally if you if
you did an honest accounting any
long-term care resident whether they
died in the facility or at the hospital
if you count all of that which Florida
does you'd have a majority of the covin
related fatalities would be residents of
long-term care facilities nationwide and
I think that's true in a lot of these
other countries and so if you want to
know where the risk of mortality is from
the corona virus you know you've got you
know between 100 150 thousand folks in
these facilities in Florida and they
represent over half of the of the
fatalities in the state and so we're
gonna continue to put a lot of emphasis
on protecting the most vulnerable to
this virus social distancing we
obviously a lot of we stress this and
have been I know as things kind of
changed a little bit at the end of May
beginning of June
you know there were a lot you saw a lot
more large gatherings you saw different
things and I don't know if maybe people
thought the social distancing you know
it's kind of yesterday's news it's it's
important to continue doing it and so
we're really pointing out the best way
you can protect yourself but
particularly protect our most vulnerable
and slow the spread is to avoid closed
spaces crowded places in close contact
settings and sometimes that can be all
three I mean if you're at a at a private
party inside an air-conditioned house
and you guys are people are
shoulder-to-shoulder and you're talking
over music or something you know that is
going to be incredible vector for
transmission when you're in closed and
closed spaces particularly with air
conditioning you're gonna see more of
transmission than you would if you were
in even if you're inside if it's a
little more spacious and certainly
obviously if you're outside but the
social distancing is important because
if you do it you know you're not going
to get infected if you're maintaining
the appropriate distance now we
also said now since May that if you
can't social distance you know wearing a
facial covering can cut down on the
transmission we believe some but it's
not in lieu of social distance you can
social distance you still want to do
that because that's the best way to
prevent infections whether you infecting
somebody else or somebody else infecting
you
so those close spaces crowded places in
close contact settings really are what
makes this thing spread and there are we
now know I think pretty clearly you know
outdoors fresh air sunlight heat
humidity it's less risk it doesn't mean
it's no risk I mean if you're very close
and doing things like you know
definitely but if you're just outside
you know the chance of you acquiring
this from fleeting contact from somebody
you know it's very very low you know the
higher risks are those includes crowded
spaces with the poor ventilation Florida
I think you're seeing you know you're
seeing all this happen throughout the
Sunbelt from the Carolinas to Southern
California places like Arizona Texas
Florida that are hot in the summer you
know people tend to want to retreat
inside to the air-conditioning and
that's understandable but if you have
groups of people in the air-conditioning
that is gonna be better for the virus
than if you were outside in the sunshine
and that's I think been proven over and
over again and so different environments
carry different risks and so as best you
can you know minimize a lot of contacts
in those high-risk environments so we
talked about back in March the manager
was flatten the curve I mean people
don't really gets talked about that as
much anymore but the theory behind it
was you know if you had infections just
spike
you could have patients flooding the
hospital the system may not be able to
handle it so we wanted to slow the
spread we couldn't end the spread and
obviously you know I've said we're gonna
have cases you know going forward but
it's it's allowed us to be in a position
to be able to better handle you know
what's going on you know back at the end
of March we had seven state supported
testing sites by April first we had
tested 20,000 people in those sites
which at the
wasn't bad I mean there weren't tests
available everywhere you kind of had to
do what you had to do but that was what
we what we did to date right now we have
47 different testing sites and just
those sites of loan have done almost
600,000 tests and so the sites we have
we have drive-thru sites we have walk-up
sites we have pop-up retail sites we
have a mobile RV that will go around in
different parts of Florida and test
people so you've seen more and more
testing available across the state of
Florida and obviously what the state is
doing you know it's just part of it I
mean the hospitals are doing a lot
you've got other the locals are doing
stuff private sector but we're now in a
situation where there's a lot of these
test sites in a way that just wasn't the
case in March not only here but anywhere
in the country in May you know when our
numbers were low I was begging people to
get tested some of these places had
relatively light traffic now in the past
a few weeks now that traffic has
increased so the capacity has increased
some of the like the Orange County
Convention Center that would do about
500 tests a day you know now they're
doing 17 50 a day and they've expanded
lanes and done some of the other things
some of these retail sites would do 25 a
day now some of them are doing 150 a day
so you've definitely seen more of an
interest in getting tested which is good
one thing we are going to do though is
make available on a wider basis antibody
testing and the reason is is you've got
a lot of people now who are testing who
aren't presenting with symptoms maybe
because of work maybe because someone
they know got infected and you know the
problem is if you're negative it doesn't
mean that you can't get it the next day
I mean it's a really a fleeting thing to
have a negative test if you do an
antibody test and you have the
antibodies well that's something that's
very significant in terms of the
information and so for somebody if
you're not symptomatic those antibody
tests really would be good they can
detect a recent infection if you have
IgM antibodies that means that you've
likely been infected within a relatively
recent
time I Gigi antibodies would be you know
at least two weeks prior maybe longer
than that but right now we've been doing
it for health care workers and for first
responders but I think it's important
for folks to be able to have access to
that so we're gonna be working on ways
that we can get more antibody testing
out the good thing about the antibody
test you get the results in 15 minutes
bad part is it's a blood test it's not a
swab so some people would rather be swab
and have then have the blood taken but
it is good information to have so we're
gonna be working on that but the testing
is so much better today than it was in
March and April and that includes the
hospitals as well as the state of
Florida another major issue that we were
concerned about in March and April was
personal protective equipment
particularly for first responders and
healthcare workers our department of
emergency management has sent out huge
amount of resources to hospitals but
particularly to long-term care
facilities we imposed PPE mandate on
them in March and then we sent in 95
mass we've sent face shields we send
gowns
we've sent this stuff to them obviously
we've also helped the hospitals with
things that they've needed now most I
have not talked to any hospitals who are
having problems with PPE at this point
which is a great thing and so but we're
in a much better position than we were
prior to prior to April you also see
part of the reason I think the fatality
rate is lower is because you have better
treatments today than you did in in
March we brought a lot of
hydroxychloroquine to Florida to have
that as an option a lot of physicians
you've used it the whole time and liked
it there was a study that came out in
The Lancet that had to be withdrawn that
said it was bad
now Henry Ford medical in Detroit says
this is this has been very helpful
bottom line is we want to provide that
for physicians to make those decisions
with their patients the convalescent
plasma has had success the remm des
abeer which we work with HHS to get to
the hospitals has had success and then
you've got things like the steroid and
these other therapies so the patient
experience is much better today than it
would have been in
in March or the beginning of April and
obviously the physicians have learned a
lot about the virus which is a which is
a really really good thing so flattening
the curve you know you are pushing
infections out longer means you have to
deal with it longer but I think in terms
of outcomes you'd much rather be in a
situation now than have to have done
this you know at higher levels in March
and April in terms of positive outcomes
so support the healthcare system one of
our main pillars there's a couple things
that I think some of the the folks have
asked for one is I was with the Vice
President on Thursday they obviously
want to be helpful in any way they can
one of the things that we see a need for
is some personnel support for some of
our hospital systems and the reason is
is you know they we have 15,000 plus
beds available the census 25% are
available obviously hospitals you'd want
to run probably at ninety percent
capacity
normally so so the beds are there the
issue is is how the personnel can be
used so for example in miami-dade you
know their largest hospital system
Jackson they have almost 40% of the
people that come in for non Cova things
like car accident childbirth are testing
positive now they're asymptomatic they
don't need to be hospitalized for kovat
but once somebody tests positive there's
a whole set of procedures that then get
put in place it requires manpower so
that those folks are isolated and
they're the Cova doesn't spread to other
people and so what they're finding is is
okay you get someone gets in a car
accident they get swab they're positive
they don't need to be hospitalized for
COBIT but they do need care for other
things that still requires kind of the
kovat procedures to be put in place so
having a little bit of relief on that
element and there's different things
that they can do would be good so we've
put in that request we think it'll be
favorably granted and we hope to have
some folks down you know they're they're
fine now but just looking at
particularly as you see certain
communities where there's a higher
positivity rate well that's going to be
reflected in the general patient
population who come in to
ooh apart from from from Cova 19 so
they're kind of at the higher end with
the 40% but even some of the ones in
Central Florida like Orlando health I
think they said they're about 20% of the
people coming in for other things that
gets swab you know do test positive and
again these are people I think 99% are
asymptomatic or most of them are
asymptomatic and they don't require
hospitalization for coronavirus but
nevertheless those procedures need to be
put in place and that just that just
requires a lot of care and a lot of lot
of manpower and they've had a lot of
people working very hard for months and
then the summer time is the lower season
for Florida typically in terms of staff
and so this is an important request the
remm des aveer we want to make sure that
that continues flowing the HHS had been
sending it directly to the Department of
Health and then Florida was distributing
it to all the hospitals based upon need
it's worked very well but now what
they're doing is they're going from the
manufacturer directly to the hospitals
which is fine but we just want to make
sure that there's no gap there so we're
working with the White House on that and
then finally just some of the chemicals
for the labs they're doing a lot of
testing in these hospitals and so
they're running out of some of this
stuff I know this stuff's available
throughout the country and so we hope to
be able to get it you know when we had
lower numbers we wouldn't get anything
because they were sending it to places
that were higher so the fact that we
have these cases we're running a lot of
tests people get that the hospitals need
to be able to turn around these tests
very quickly so that's something that
we're going to be working on really
significantly so we're better prepared
now and I think that the steps to
protect our most vulnerable is the
clearly the most important thing you
know that we can do to minimize the
impact of the corona virus and I know
we're working very hard not just at the
state level all our localities and the
federal government working side by side
with us we're gonna have hear from some
of the physicians and then we'll have a
little discussion and then we can open
up the floor for some questions and so a
dr. Nelson if you want to just one one
thank you for having us you want to just
kick it off and make some comments Thank
You governor better Thank You governor
my name is Dave Nelson I'm the president
of UF health which means I
see the Gainesville Jacksonville campus
as well as two beautiful hospitals here
in the villages I'd like to give maybe a
little reflection at a system level for
what we're dealing with in terms of
covin 19 and then I'll let my colleagues
give you more specifics
so other than overseeing the health
systems we're also responsible for
bringing back the University of Florida
and the professional schools at the
different universities for UF health and
so just to give you an idea we currently
have done well over 40,000 tests and so
we have been testing a lot throughout
this current pandemic we use a technique
called pooling which is we don't do a
single test ten people in the audience
we take tests and if it's negative all
ten are negative if anyone's positive
you go back and have to test each one
it's a resource that allows you to save
those precious reagents that the
governor just talked about and it allows
us to turn a thousand tests a day into
10,000 tests a day it's just an example
so we have probably over tests it I
think if many people had asked but we're
very interested in ensuring a safe
health care system and a safe University
for the students to come back to in the
last week or two we've seen I think what
everyone has been talking about we have
seen a dramatic increase number of
asymptomatic employees and students
which we just tested 20,000 in the last
few weeks but to put things in
perspective we went from 0.1% 0.12 1% so
if you're walking in off the streets of
Alachua County it's coming back to work
the likelihood of having asymptomatic
infection is much lower than much of the
rest of the state so we've been very
fortunate however in our three
healthcare systems we have last week saw
a spike in diagnosis cases as the
governor referred to them and we had a
little over 500 positives if you look at
the median age and where they distribute
Gainesville Jacksonville Central Florida
health were kind of one two and three
but an interesting median age of around
25 was occurring outside of the hospital
which are all around 58 so we're seeing
young people coming to the emergency
room or coming to the healthcare system
to get tested and we're seeing I think
the age pushback in terms of who's
getting hospitalized probably in that
mid to late 50s which is a change I
think from our early experience that was
dominated unfortunately about the
nursing home patients and those with
very heavy comorbidities and so overall
if you look at health care capacity so
we test a lot we're seeing a fair amount
of disease it's in the young so how are
our three big health care system stacked
up to take a second or third peak right
now all three of our health care systems
have very good capacity I think there's
a lot of misconception in the general
public when you hear that let's just say
our Gainesville campus is 90% full
that's a good thing because we're
usually closer to a hundred percent full
because we need to run fully to service
to serve our community we have triggers
that we can turn the governor turned one
before which helped us decompress which
is elective surgeries and you know we
can continue to evaluate but at least so
far in the Central Florida Health
hospitals and our Gainesville and
Jacksonville community we have
significant capacity and don't see that
being a problem but we probably could go
tenfold higher than we saw in what you
would see is the first wave because we
never got into the mitigation strategies
because we didn't see what South Florida
hit there's no doubt Miami will have a
little less capacity than the UF health
system because we had never got the
positive rates of 15 or 20% so anyway
overall I think we're definitely seeing
a common younger person's spread
hospitals are getting more active and we
will continue to watch those numbers but
have many triggers to pull to open up a
system more if we need to great dr.
Sproul once you talk about a little bit
about the the IDI and some of the stuff
that you've been seeing throughout those
many months this one all right
I'm Jeremy sprite I'd like to first of
all thanks governor de Santos for coming
here and speaking with us it's important
that he gets a lot of information from
the physicians that that are
this every day and it shows in your
control of the data which is very
important and I'm the medical director
of the emergency department here at the
villages and also the vice chief of
staff for the medical staff you know one
of the slides that he put up there was
one that reflected what the CDC reported
about severity of other illnesses and
we're not just seeing an increase in the
severity but also in the mortality
associated with a2 so heart attack
stroke other infectious illnesses aside
from kovat patients are waiting and
they're not coming in that's getting a
little bit better but still you know to
this day we're seeing patients that
should have been here earlier that has a
direct effect on their overall health
there's gonna be issues with delays and
cancer diagnosis for not just reaching
out and coming to the ER but also to
even their primary care physician so you
know my job today is to let the public
know and reassure them that our policies
that we have and procedures and
screening patients and visitors and and
staff on a daily basis that the
hospitals are very very safe and you
know we're here and and ready and if
you've got anything that you're
concerned about you know come in don't
delay great dr. Lizardo can you talk
about some of the stuff you're saying
and then obvious um of the nursing home
component so if you speak about that as
well absolutely Thank You governor very
much for having us here and for coming
to to be with us here at UF health kovat
presents some unprecedented challenges
things that none of us have seen during
our careers and probably one of the
biggest challenges is the wide range of
outcomes related to age so in other
words in one group you see very little
bad outcomes and another group to seek
devastating outcomes but I remain
optimistic
it's a bounded optimism so it's got its
limits but I'm still very optimistic and
why is that the reason being is that you
know the governor said it himself is
that probably the single most important
intervention that we've done has been to
focus on the nursing homes and I
couldn't agree more when you look at
that idea of testing repeatedly and
going in every two weeks to ensure that
that's where you watch that population
the most then not only
the workers but also the residents and
long-term care facilities that has been
a huge huge breakthrough and that's a
very important step to take so that
moves and makes a big change and affects
probably the single most important risk
group in terms of mortality them really
the outcome that matters the most but
secondly I said a bounded optimism the
bounded optimism is that what's been
driving what's been going on here lately
and it's been behavior as the father of
a 21 year old and a 15 year old I get it
I understand kind of what some of the
challenges are but much of what we've
seen lately is behavior driven and again
yes we want to see that stay in the age
groups but again that fear is that
unmitigated behavior so in other words
just kind of thinking of now and not
thinking of tomorrow or thinking of
others that spills over into other age
groups and then we've got another
problem so again I think that we have
the tools we have a lot of steps so we
can move forward but again we need
everybody to work with us on that so
follow the rules follow the guidelines
try to think about others as well I know
so many people are doing it and this is
a long haul there's some challenges here
but there's a lot of reason to be
optimistic and I think that those steps
will make a big difference and
especially with those younger age groups
thinking about others trying to put off
some of those things think about the
ones you love those are gonna be the
steps gonna real help all of us continue
to get this under control and continue
to have reasons for optimism moving
forward great thanks all right dr. Lowe
and cron you want to weigh in on some of
the stuff we talked about
sure so Jeff long cron chief medical
officer for the villages health probably
the only representative of an outpatient
system here is the ability to talk to
folks before they're sick and part of
what we need to be able to do is assure
they have a confidence to be able to
speak with us either in person which
will welcome them into the care centers
or in whatever way they want to reach
out to us the real key is that we as the
healthcare delivery system
have to make sure they're safe when they
come in so we're making sure and we've
been doing this for months now we screen
people on the way in we keep our own
folks who are working there safe and we
keep the people that they're coming in
contact with safe by doing that we
assure that they can get the care they
need you know the real key is this most
people as they get older don't need a
hospital stay every year but they all
need a primary care visit every year so
we've seen demand for services come down
for inpatient for in person but our
ability to still make sure we deliver on
the high quality service that we can is
key and what we know is if they need to
come to the hospital they're gonna get
outstanding and safe care here as well
so with that we've been pretty
comfortable sending our patients here
when they need to but we do start out by
making sure they need to come so thank
you and I mean just for the course of
this pandemic like particularly the
residents at the villages it seems like
they've really you know taken some of
the guidelines to heart and you know
there's still they still do things
obviously because they're very active
Bunch but they've they've done it in a
way that that's minimized risk is that
been your experience it has been and I
think one of the things that really
doesn't get the credit that it deserves
so the leadership here at the hospital
and our leadership and the Department of
Health in the counties here have gotten
together to assure we're giving a clear
consistent message as to what's been
expected and that clarity and that
communication plan has been in place
since March so we've had ongoing
almost initially daily sometimes two or
three times daily conversations now it's
probably just twice a week and I know
that they've there were certain things
some of the you know big indoor
gatherings whatever they stopped in
March and they've continued to monitor
and I think that they had planned on
maybe doing something sometime this
month but I think they were just waiting
on that and so that's very much you know
focusing on on the facts and and making
those decisions and so you know I think
from the very beginning remember when I
when I called Gary at the beginning of
March and you know they they had a plan
and they've executed and that's really
what you need to do and that's part of
the reasons you've had the very low
numbers I'm here even though you have a
more elderly population dr. Nelson
across your system we've heard
throughout different parts of Florida
that March and April patients that we're
presenting we're presenting you know
they tend to be older very sick now
maybe a not
younger maybe a notch milder is that
what you guys are saying in terms of
your kovat positive patients yeah I
would say that's accurate also we're so
much smarter right we know how to put
people down on prone position we know
probably not everyone needs a ventilator
we have Ren de severe and steroids that
have a role in in hospitalization so not
only do I think we have a little bit
either different virus or patient who's
getting exposed but you know we've just
got so much more knowledge that we
learned from the new yorks and the
connecticut's and the rest of the world
that kind of taught us you know things
that would have saved probably lives
back then so I think we're all getting
better and hopefully we'll get some new
therapeutics or a vaccine down the road
to make it a little easier absolutely
so dr. spry in terms of the AED visits
you guys saw decline how much of a
decline did you see and how long did
that decline and where are you now are
you back to normal for things like heart
and stroke symptoms yeah we had about a
40 to 50 percent decrease in overall
daily volley medicine wasn't here in
Central Florida
that's all throughout the entire country
even my friends that where I trained in
Detroit the covet capital their volumes
were down as well
now volumes had picked up we're still
down about 10% but we're not where we
were typically you know even in this
seasonal area right here so because
there was a decline and I think most
people don't think that all of a sudden
people stopped having heart attacks or
strokes the people that eventually would
come to probably should have come are
they coming in worse condition yeah
absolutely and we said the same thing
what happened to appendicitis what
happened to heart attacks so you know
where did they all go it just doesn't
disappear so that they are there waiting
and when they come in they're having
issues with more significant congestive
heart failure because they wrote out
their heart attack at the house or
they're laying on the floor for three
days not wanting to come in and get help
we've seen several Falls at home that
typically just tried to make it
themselves so it is very important that
you don't ignore these things just
because we're in the middle of the
pandemic and you're and you're concerned
about you know the state of the hospital
great all right well I want to thank you
guys for for having us here thanks for
all the good work you're doing thanks to
the villages for really going about it
in a really really smart way
and protect in their their residents and
of course we want to continue to do that
you know as we've seen this positivity
rise as we see you know 15 percent and
in communities maybe not quite 15
percent here but in a lot of parts of
laura de as you start to see that it's
very very important you know that we
continue protecting the vulnerable
obviously we've got a big apparatus in
place with the long term care facilities
very important but also are 65 and up
population that that they're minimizing
large crowds and contact close contact
with people outside their homes and
folks who aren't in that age group or
don't necessarily have comorbidities you
know to understand that particularly in
the 20 and 30s you're seeing this thing
circulate more widely and look this was
probably circulating amongst that age
group in March or April we just weren't
testing for it but I do think it's
circulating at a higher rate now or
certainly has in the last few weeks than
it would have been detected even if we
were testing a little bit more
aggressively so that's out there and so
what you want to do is is just be
cognizant of that particularly in those
20s and 30s you do see more infections
there than than anywhere else any other
age cohort and so grandmother parent
please keep that in mind over these over
these next couple weeks with that well
happy to take some questions yes ma'am
no no the theme parks have been doing
great I mean Universal if you look at
what they're doing and that's I think
the lesson is you can do you we have to
have society function you can have
society function in a way that keeps
people safe and when you have all the
different procedures that they have in
place people are gonna be it's a safe
environment Disney I have no doubt it's
gonna be a safe environment I think that
where you start to see the spread it's
just in social situations where people
let their guard down usually like a
private party or something like that
that's kind of what we've seen so but I
think that the folks who put a premium
on safety that's showing you that you
know we're able to handle this have
society function we still want people
going to work but do it in a way that
you take some basic precautions and so I
really impressed with what universals
done and I've looked at Disney's plan I
mean it was very very thorough they've
been doing a good job I mean that's you
know here's the thing you see where this
where the virus is spreading and in the
age groups it's spreading in you know we
need to protect the vulnerable we need
to protect the folks who are in the
at-risk age groups people with
comorbidities but but the broader part
of society you know doing the moderate
social distancing doing the basic things
will go a long way and so that's what we
need to do we need to keep keep people
working keep society functioning and and
combat it that way and I and I think we
will what else is new they were doing
that in March to remember that
obviously we're I mean we're doing so
much in terms of of combating this from
the beginning I mean if you look just
look at what we've done with these kovat
only nursing homes I mean like that's
saving lives so we're doing all that we
can do on that so obviously you know I
went through the numbers I want us to be
in May I want us to be in early June
where we're at 3 4 % I mean there were
times in Central Florida
I mean Orange County sometimes they'd
have days they'd be one and a half two
percent would be positive not in really
if you're at one have 2% that's
basically false positive right there may
have been nobody that actually was
infected it wanted out so we want to get
back to that for sure I think that I
think we're I think we've stabilized
that where we're at and you know other
states can do what they want but you go
back and look at March the positivity
rates in some of those areas in 115
percent I mean it was 40 50 60 percent
daily in some of those areas so it's a
little bit different and I would also
say Florida is very diverse as many of
you know you know we have one major
metro area in South Florida that has the
highest numbers both in terms of
positivity and in terms of and in terms
of IDI visits and hospital usage and
then we have others you know if you look
at like Central Florida no doubt you've
seen way more cases in like Orange
County but the median age sometimes is
in the 20s on a daily basis never below
above I think like the mid 30s and so
the clinical consequences of that has
been has been relatively mild I mean
Orange County has one of the lowest case
fatality rates for the amount of people
you know that you have so there's a lot
it's not an even epidemic throughout the
state there's a lot of diversity here
obviously I think you know the solutions
are going to be tailored differently
based on the facts at hand but I think
that we you know we're much better off
today than we were in March and we're
much better off to to web
compared to what some of those other
areas are so yeah the look they can do
what they wanted for I would not I would
not do that if I were them when I took
the action against the Northeast it was
factually the case that tens of
thousands were coming to Miami right at
the height I didn't necessarily want to
do it hell I got a lot of private
blowback because I know people that
travel back and forth and they told me
they're like look we're fine and I just
did it because I thought that that was
the safe thing to do and I think in
hindsight you look back South Florida
had it worse than largely because I
think of that of that being seated you
didn't see the seating as much in
central or North Florida and so it was
milder in March and April in May here
now I think this part is starting to see
you know more cases or whatever so but
we're really I mean it's a team effort
here in Florida we've got all hands on
deck and I think the people of Florida
are responding positively and I think
they're responding in ways like look
there's no need to be fearful let's just
focus on the facts we understand what
we've got to do as a state and let's
let's get it done I mean I think if we
do that you know we're gonna be in we're
gonna be in good shape and I do think
you know to listen to some of the things
you know that you hear from some of the
folks in the hospital systems you know
they understand you know they prepare
for this I mean this is what they what
they have to deal with so we're in
constant contact with all those folks as
I mentioned the personnel that we're
going to bring down is largely because
of non Kovan related illnesses that
people are in for other reasons they
test positive for kovat and all the
procedures that then go in that then
takes away some of the manpower so we
want to be able to help supplement that
the room des of your all these things
we're going to continue to do that and I
think do it do it very well so so we're
gonna we're going to be okay well I
think if you look so you saw I'm not
sure exactly what he meant you know in
Florida the case fatality rate is under
two percent now which is much lower than
a lot of these other states now
obviously you know if you don't die some
people have nasty illnesses and hospital
stays and we shouldn't minimize that I
mean obvi
we're focused number one on the
fatalities the care homes in those areas
so you do that but I do think if you
look at the infections on top of just
the cases which may be ten times as many
you know the rate of lethality is much
lower in an infection fatality rate than
a case fatality rate and it's something
I mean even the CDC has said point two
six percent I will say though for the
people that are testing positive at the
highest rates in Florida those twenty
year olds and the thirty by and large
they're presenting very mild or
asymptomatic aliy and that's obviously a
good thing it's it's good thing in terms
of the health outcomes now it makes it
harder to contain the spread because if
this was SARS one I don't even think you
were contagious until you were really
ill and so you'd get ill you could
isolate and you really could stop it
here most of the people who have it
under 50 are not exhibiting symptoms or
very very minor symptoms not enough
where they would want to go seek medical
attention no no well I'm not minimizing
it but I but I think we should also have
proper perspective when we went into
this you know there were people saying
that you know 20 year old was just as at
risk as a 90 year old and that's just
not factually true we know where the
risk is we know who the comorbidities
that are impacted we've got data on this
now we know who the folks who are more
vulnerable who need to be protected so
it's a very serious thing and I don't
think he was trying to minimize it but I
mean clearly we've we viewed as serious
from the beginning in January when we
were monitoring it but at the same time
when you hear news about cases I just
think that should be put in the proper
context and perspective that the number
one age for cases in Florida is 21 and
if you're 21 and you don't have
significant comorbidities your your
fatality rate is pretty much zero with
that and so that's that that's good to
me that's comforting to know when you
see the cases that it's affecting folks
who are less likely to see clinical
consequences than some folks and I've
said this before even before we start to
see more cases
a clinical perspective a thousand cases
under the age of 30 is gonna be less
significant than 50 cases in a long-term
care facility that's just the way this
virus works it's very much dependent on
age and on the comorbidities well what I
would want to see I think in there
discussing it in the Congress and this
next round if they do do a next round is
is is providing people if they do go
back to work and take their old jobs may
be a financial premium to do that
because right now there is a
disincentive depending on where your
wage is if you had some type of premium
then if there's more of an incentive to
want to go back and so so I think that
they should structure it differently but
I but I would support them doing
something to be able to you know to get
people to keep them on their feet get
them back in the workforce
and do I mean we've seen a lot of people
get back in their jobs after the kind of
the march/april shutdown the problem is
that I see is you know some of those
jobs are definitely going to come back
but the question is there gonna be 50
percent 90 percent
I mean if it's 50 percent you know
you're gonna have some problems if it's
90 percent you know we're gonna be able
to kind of deal with it so here in
Florida you know we obviously haven't
had the job numbers yet for for our
state in particular but if you look at
the national numbers you know we're
obviously anticipating a positive
positive increase here in Florida to be
reflected from June and then obviously
we want to continue to do that as we
move forward and in a very safe way well
I want to thank the folks here again for
all their hard work I want to thank dr.
Nelson for partnering with the state on
a number of very neat projects you know
we did a surveillance project at the
villages I think I was probably March or
April pretty early on and we wanted to
try to figure out what percentage of
people are asymptomatic because at that
time you wouldn't even get a test
unless you had symptoms which a lot of
people testing positive now probably
would not have met the criteria but at
that time there was an age component and
there was a symptomatic component and we
said okay you know that makes sense
because we had limited resources but
what about asymptomatic seniors so they
test it I think would you do 2,200 or
1400 4000 they did 4,000 asymptomatic
seniors and not a single infection right
less than 1% mean you know I think the
first round they did they got zero than
they did more they got a few but I mean
very very low prevalence now part of
that is they were doing a good job here
at the villages part of it I think as we
now know is you know you didn't see this
really come through Florida outside of
South Florida until we got into June so
I'll bet you if we did it there probably
be higher now hopefully still pretty low
because they've done a really good job
here but that's just something that and
then UF health they started doing the
testing in low-income neighborhoods
public housing and that really provided
the inspiration for us to do all of our
walk-up sites so we have all these
walk-up sites and underserved or
low-income neighborhoods in different
parts of the state now where people
could go at a tough time getting a lot
of people to test in May and then all of
a sudden in June now we got a lot of
people going through those sites as well
but that's what they're there for for
people to be able to be able to do that
and so what they did in Jacksonville
really informed us to say okay it's one
thing to have a big drive through site
it's one thing for the hospitals or a
doctor's office to do it but we really
need to bring testing to the people and
get it in areas which are very
convenient for folks and quite frankly
not everyone has access to a vehicle all
the time so we wanted to do that and
it's been very very successful so we
look forward to working with you one
thing I would like to see is you know I
think we need a statewide scientifically
valid statewide seroprevalence
study so if you guys are interested in
helping with that we've we have one
University of Miami miami-dade we have
this dated one from the CDC now for
Southern Florida but that is really
really important to know the
seroprevalence
throughout the state because the higher
the seroprevalence the less the ability
the virus is going to have to spread so
some of these areas you know that have
hit 15-20 percent you know the virus
doesn't doesn't expand as much so if you
have a very low seroprevalence then it's
got more more potential targets to reach
so I think it's very important not only
as we get through this period but not
knowing what may happen you know in the
fall and as we get into flu season to
have that source of information I think
it's gonna be very very important so we
want to work to get that done all right
thanks everybody
you